hello everyone we're from the cast of
marvel studios shanxi and the legend of
the 10 rings and today we're going to
play a game that'll hopefully let you
know a little bit more about our
characters
you got this don't be nervous thank you
who is most likely to get into a fight
me
that sounds fast yes right yes like your
character or you i just want to make
sure that you know also you
you're like such a badass everything
that you do is like so cool who is most
likely to joke their way out of a
confrontation you you think it's me sean
would would make a snarky
like uh well let's go big boy
shawn is known to say that i'm ready to
rumble that's right what i don't know
what what men say why so big big boy
who's most likely to survive a zombie
apocalypse both of you guys
[Music]
you have superhero genetics are you
kidding me but here's the thing how many
times can you punch a zombie
without like without getting bit um
right who's most likely to fall for a
phone scammer definitely me and that was
one time
and it was just my social
no really a couple times
who's most likely to order a coffee
drink with more than five words i don't
know i've never done that character work
before i got to really reach down and go
like
what does my character want
for coffee who is most likely to save
the world
trick question
all of us it's all of us we save the
world together because we're a super
team